this week we're talking about retail on
the cloud cloud run and scaling s IP I'm
Stephanie and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the Lois Lane C
news with 700 stores longtime retailer
Macy's has looked to Google cloud for
data management and analytics Google
Labs CEO Thomas Kurian dives into how
GCP is helping them streamline
operational functions check out the full
article to learn more about how Google
cloud is helping retails for faster
smarter and more securely so you're
excited about the release of no 12 and
you just can't wait for systems to add
new versions support why not run now and
Google cloud run using the functions
framework and a little bit of code cloud
run can be set up to easily deploy a
note 12 function breeze through this
step-by-step guide by grant Timmerman
still searching for reasons to start
building on cloud run how about 12 more
check out this blog post to learn
exactly how cloud run complies with each
part of the 12 factor app methodology
it's simple
these factors act as a blueprint to
build applications that are scalable
portable and agile take a look to learn
how cloud run and the 12 factors square
up you can see why cloud run makes it
easy to scale serverless apps but what
about apps running on virtual machines
like s AP server
check out these best practices for
scaling s AP server on google cloud and
you'll also get an in-depth comparison
of the two main approaches utilization
based auto scaling and schedule based
scaling get ready for the intelligent
enterprise if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link have thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the club
you